the red wave warning growing more
intense for democrats as president biden
continues his freefall in the polls
swing state voters are reportedly
getting buyers remorse with the
president's approval sinking fast in
several battleground states like
michigan virginia and iowa and making
matters worse for biden the democratic
party is currently feuding over aspects
of his trillion-dollar spending agenda
okay
on the one hand you know joe biden i'll
start with you dana joe biden started
out saying he was going to unify
everybody and now it appears he can't
even unify his own party because he's on
the one hand he's got these leftist
progressive democrats and then he's got
the more moderate democrats and now he's
got the 3.5 trillion dollar spending
bill uh that is you know apparently
causing a lot of people to say we didn't
set we didn't vote for him to do this
one of the reasons biden said that he
won the primary for with the democrats
is that he was more moderate and then he
wasn't progressive like bernie sanders
and then he became president and all of
a sudden he's being led around by the
nose by the progressives and the bernie
sanders crowd and the moderates who
actually have very tough races who
would need something to bring home they
want this infrastructure bill and then
they'll talk about the um 3.5 trillion
that the 3.5 trillion that's got the
progressives all worried so now they're
at a stalemate that's why they instead
of meeting with republicans today to try
to get them to
support the bills he's having to meet
with his own people and mostly he might
have some success there they might
figure out a way to save some face and
bring some things together but one of
the problems is he is mishandling all
these other issues we've talked about
the border afghanistan
and inflation also being another issue
that and crime let me add that one
it's making his political capital
account decrease well you know in
addition to that i mean you look at iowa
i mean his approval rating is 31 percent
in iowa i mean that is that's pretty
still higher than geraldo's though yeah
but
his job reports not in cleveland yeah
but his job approval is 43 overall but
iowa which is a really important state
31 it's like don't even show up there
but but here's the thing joe's approval
was at his highest when he wasn't
working so when he was in hiding he was
it was he was the
player to be named later or other right
and then the more he does his job right
the faster his approval evaporates so my
solution for him if i was running
his if i was his chief of staff
cryogenics
freeze him until 2022 defrost him like a
swanson's dinner bake back better
that would be his new thing because
right now
everything you're saying is correct
nobody's buying moderate joe anymore
he's like that was one
geraldo will remember this he's like
those one-dimensional towns that they
used in western tv shows yeah they can
fool you until you it suddenly just
falls over i think you're discriminating
against older people
yeah but what do you say i'm as sharp as
i've ever been yeah uh i i think that
joe biden's coattails are clearly
shrinking and i think that the biggest
impact is not the midterm election i
think you've got this 3.5 trillion
dollar you know omnibus spending bill
that requires all 50 senators i think
cinema and mansion the two rebels
will be empowered by his his diminishing
popularity and if you can't get 50
senators on the floor and will this also
collapse the infrastructure bill the 1.9
trillion dollar infrastructure bill will
this hamper his ability to uh you know
lift the debt ceiling and all the rest
of it i i think that if he is as wounded
as this before the first year is even
out i think it does spell problems i'm
no big political expert but it seems to
me it spell's problem well you know
jesse with mansion and cinema uh you
know they can't convince them to turn
around joe biden yes and i'll be brief
because i want to save time for
geraldo's apology to gut fell
but i don't know if you've noticed this
judge but my friends and family who are
democrats they don't defend biden
i asked them and how's it going guys
they say oh okay don't look at me and
it's true it's like no one's a biden
voter it's like being a carter voter it
has a a stench that's wafting around
from it because everything
dies and then he lies about it and hides
so we know what's going on with joe it's
a matter of in next year is he going to
be so toxic in these swing states in the
30s still that are other democrats
running are they going to distance
themselves exactly from joe biden that's
what do you think i think if he remains
on this course yes okay the fastest is
up next hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else